Nottinghamshire police have confirmed
that a 31 year old man has been arrested
on suspicion of murder after three
people were killed in Nottingham City
Center early on Tuesday morning
the same individual is suspected of
stealing a van and then running over
another three people who are now being
treated for their injuries one of whom
remains in critical condition
we know that a knife has been used in
these attacks
and two of the victims were students at
Nottingham University
the third victim was the owner of the
van that police suspect was stolen and
used to run down those pedestrians
I know that the whole house will join me
in expressing our sorrow and that our
thoughts and prayers are with the
victims families friends and all those
affected
all of us extend the hand of friendship
to the people of Nottingham
I'm of course being fully kept and being
kept fully informed by law enforcement
on the ground and receiving regular
updates
Mr Speaker the house will appreciate the
critical importance of following due
process at all times
it's completely natural to seek answers
immediately when something terrible
happens
but it's also vital that those answers
are wholly accurate
speculating out loud is never helpful
and runs the risk of being
counterproductive
the police have asked for patience while
the inquiries continue Mr Speaker
I can tell the house that the police are
working flat out to establish the full
facts and provide support to everyone
affected
they are currently keeping an open mind
as to the motives Behind these attacks
but I can confirm Nottinghamshire police
are being assisted in their inquiries by
counter-terror police though this does
not mean that it is currently being
treated as a terrorist attack
I'm grateful to all our emergency
services for being on the scene and
dealing in a professional manner with a
deeply distressing situation
we all owe them a huge debt of gratitude
at awful moments like this Mr Speaker it
is vital that we come together as a
country
and I have no doubt that we will
the city of Nottingham and all its
people are at the Forefront of all our
minds
and every resource of the state is at
their disposal